why do bad things happen to good people
yeah why does god allow this kind of
thing to happen
and uh sort of maybe an unanswerable
question do you have an answer to that
question i can gesture toward it using
rather abstract language which is true
enough
it's completely emotionally unsatisfying
but it's naming it truthfully enough and
it goes back to augustine which is
god
permits
evil to bring about a greater good
now again i know how unsatisfying that
sort of spare austere language can sound
but it gets us off the horn of the horns
of a dilemma you know acquaintance you
know when he lays out a question he
always has the objections first so is
there a god well objection one objection
to objection three and he's really talk
about steel manning and argument aquinas
is great at that
um
one of the really steel manned arguments
is that the right grammatical form
one of the what's the past participle
about the steel man um
but one of the best
arguments he formulates this way
um
if one of two contraries be infinite the
other would be altogether destroyed
and as an example from his medieval
physics he goes if there were infinite
heat there'd be no cold right but god is
described as
infinitely good
therefore if god exists there should be
no evil
but there is evil therefore god does not
exist
that's a darn good argument that's a
really persuasive argument and and i
think i've done this for a long time in
apologetics and in sort of higher
philosophy um that's the best argument
against god
um but here's something before i press
ahead with it something i find really
interesting i think the three best
arguments against god all come from
within the religious tradition namely
the book of job
so job he's great i mean he's a great
guy he does everything right he's he's
god's great servant and he and he's
punished in every possible way you know
he has every possible suffering
aquinas's argument from the summa and
then
to your friend and mine uh dostoevsky i
think in the brothers karamazov
uh yvonne's argument when he's trying to
wreck the faith of aliyosha
and it's um
these examples drawn they they think
from dostoyevsky from the headlines of
his own time
of the most abject cruelty to children
like an innocent child being made to
suffer
how
in god's name could that happen if god
exists and he's all good
so i get it but see the book of job
thomas aquinas dostoevsky these are all
profoundly believing people like when i
hear um stephen fry you know the
famously atheist
writer he he will bring out this
argument with great authority he does
of you know children with bone cancer
and worms that go into the eyes of
children and blind them before they kill
them and
but he's been preceded by the author of
job thomas aquinas and dostoyevsky who
who stood right
think of job in the in the whirlwind he
stands there in the in the whirlwind you
know
so
you can't blame the christian tradition
for not dealing with this problem you
know for like uh
brushing it under the carpet i mean it
it has it has stood in the whirlwind of
this problem it's still a difficult
problem to deal with that there's all
this cruelty of the world
it's uh there's a lot of example through
history just
yeah in my own family history with the
soviet union with
uh stalin
yeah
the
atrocities that stalin has brought on to
its the people of the soviet union
throughout the 20th century is
nearly immeasurable yeah
and yet
when you look at the entirety of human
history you'll see progress not just the
soviet union but the entirety of the
civilization throughout the 20th century
and stalin has a role to play
there's a there's a dark aspect to
somehow
evil
helps us make progress
and i don't know how to put that in the
calculation
it's uh i don't you know on the local
scale i want to alleviate suffering i'm
right probably
lean heavily lean pacifist
not out of weakness but out of strength
but man
it does seem that uh history sprinkled
with evil and that evil does somehow
nudge us
towards good
yes sometimes we can see it and that's
where the that's where the idea comes
from that evil's permitted to bring
about some greater good and we can
sometimes really see it
um
can we always see it no in fact
typically we don't see it but now you
bring another factor into this which is
the difference between our minds and
god's mind so our minds i mean look even
they're remarkably capacious but they
take in a tiny tiny tiny swath of
of space and time and even like our eyes
kind of like taking so much of the light
spectrum and these little these little
ape sensorium that we have that can just
take in a a little tiny bit of reality
really
how are we ever in a position to say
oh no there's no possible good that
would ever come from that even the
greatest evil that you know every
dostoevsky and that can conjure up and
stephen fry
still how could we
have the arrogance to say
i know there's no good that could ever
come from that i know
there's no morally justifiable reason
why god would ever permit that because i
think that's hubris
to the nth degree for us to say that
and that's the assumption behind this
claim that
god can permit evil to bring about a
greater good now god understands it
but we're like
we're like little kids you know like a
four-year-old and their parents make a
decision and we say what why in the
world would you do this to me um
this is my pastoral experience years ago
there was a young father and his son was
like three or something and he was in
the hospital for something i forgot what
it was but he had to undergo surgery
right so after the surgery he's in great
pain this poor kid this three-year-old
kid and the dad was there with him
you know holding his hand and you know
and the son this is what the father told
me he said he's looking at me
like what gives here i mean why would
you you love me i i've always assumed
that
and yet you're presiding over this
somehow you're approving of this and
doing nothing to get me out of it right
and he said the kid couldn't articulate
that but his eyes did and his eye and
the father said it was just killing me
because i knew i couldn't explain it to
him
and it's true he could vaguely gesture
toward but the kid didn't understand
surgery and cutting his body and taking
things out of it and that this was gonna
you know make him much better in the
long run but i remember thinking that's
a great metaphor for us vis-a-vis god is
here's god infinitely loving god who's
with us all the time and we say
what are you doing why aren't you taking
this away from me
and the answer i mean ultimately is
trust trust me
trust me
surrender to me and when we don't that's
uh
get we get in trouble with the old pride
and the hubris and all that kind of
stuff yeah no but trust me what i tell
you i mean i completely get it in my own
life and as a priest you're dealing with
suffering all the time with people in
pain all the time i remember as a young
priest there was a uh
there was a policeman in our parish so
he had a gun and
inexplicably
no one had any clue he got up one night
shot his son to death and then shot
himself
he's in my parish so i went to the uh
the wake i remember i show up and i'm
this young 27 year old goofball priest i
might roll my collar on and i i walk in
and there were two coffins the two
coffins in the room you know there's the
son and the father
and the mother was there
and she
she went like this to me like like
she saw me okay you're the you're the
religious guy here yeah what and
just by instinct i
i went like that too i'm like
i i don't i don't know what to tell i i
can't i don't have an answer for you
but
but i was there and i'm not saying to
pat myself on the back it's just that's
where the church goes
because jesus went there see
now we're gesturing toward a more
theological response the first one is
more austerely philosophical god permits
evil to bring about a good but the
theological response is that's where
christ went is he went all the way down
he went all the way down into our
suffering
and see the cross
as the limit case of of
of evil
um
humiliation and cruelty and
institutional injustice and
psychological suffering and spiritual
suffering and death it's all there
and that's where the son of god went
and
i would say that's why as a priest i i
went there that's my job is to go to
those places you know
so that's the ultimate
answer to the problem so there is
uh we can't
comprehend it but there is meaning to
the suffering and the injustice we trust
it because
we know on other grounds of god's
existence yeah i i would resist the
claim that well this is such a such a
knock down argument so now we know there
is no god i would say no
there are all kinds of other rational
warrants for god and so i
i know that god exists i know that god
is infinite love and now i got to square
that with this experience and the way i
do that is by a trusting confidence
that god knows what he's about
you know again i know how how inadequate
that always seems to anyone who's
suffering including myself when i'm in
great suffering but i think that's the
best that we've done in the great
tradition so if you were to steal man
that
case
against god or the existence of god
you find the most convincing argument is
there's evil in the world yeah therefore
there's no god there's too much of it
yeah if i were to steal man that
argument i do what stephen fry does i
would do what dostoevsky's yvonne does i
i would do exactly that i would say
there's just too much and then if you
want to keep pressing it um animal
suffering so we talk about human
suffering but the suffering of animals
over the eons and so on um isn't there
just too much suffering to be reconciled
with a with an infinitely good god and
that's again thomas aquinas i've just
used his very
steel manned argument
you